um yo so while you're in uh incarcerated
you obviously have money signed suede on
the project that just dropped rest in
peace to him man rest in peace man I'll
let my boy straight for real real sad
situation that happened to him um did
you guys see each other in in jail at
all uh we're in the same place with
different floors so but I heard he was
there I was trying to send a kite to him
and you know but you know so you be
moving around and he had caught the
chain before me he'd went up Upstate
before me so I was like [__] it I'm
[__] around see him in reception or
something but I haven't run into him but
uh yeah that's it that's it that's a
crazy sad situation man I like for you
like hearing about that in jail like I'm
sure it's it's got to be tough right
hell yeah that [__] was crazy I'm like
man I heard about that [__] right
I was on the toilet all right somebody
come and tell me they're like oh you
know I'm like man that's some [__]
yeah that's some [__] you're like oh
no I'm like bro like I'm getting mad
because you know I hear rumors about
rappers
it's just a rumor yeah I get on the
phone I call I call my boy and he first
thing he says it's like bro I was like I
just knew when he said bro I was like
damn yeah she was [__] up I was like
what you mean like he alive though like
no I was like man that [__] that [__] it
didn't feel real to me because you feel
me was in the studio like a week before
we both turned ourselves in because he
turned himself in like a week or two
before me so we were in the studio
right there chilling chopping he was
just telling me he had a lot on his mind
too he was just like you know telling me
[__] who's making music
and then I hugged them it was like all
right then I'm gonna say I'll probably
see you in there you know yeah man
that's what it was the last time I seen
her she was so sad man it's crazy too
because both you guys are like leaders
of like
a whole new generation I feel like of of
Mexican artists coming out of Cali that
um
to me like are making music everybody
can enjoy you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah we were kind of talking earlier
like you know when I was growing up like
there was like Chicano rap which was
cool like shot a little Rob and like Mr
Capone and those guys like they were
like extremely like
right you really had to like
either be extremely [__] tapped in
with Mexican culture or be of like a
certain cough to really appreciate it
because it was Chicano rap you know what
I'm saying so I feel like yourself money
signed suede
peso peso free him like are making
records that like if you're just like
you guys are just making dope [__] and
Lee kind of like the leaders of this new
[__] in La so it's dope to see like you
get out have your head on straight you
know what I'm saying like
yeah that was another one like me and
you were talking like I mean dming but
him and I bro we were talking like for
like a year straight we just never made
the interview happen bro and I was like
damn bro and then he ended up getting
locked up and
yeah it's a sad situation man I'm sure
he's got a lot of uh I mean I hope he's
got a lot of unreal [__] that he does I
know he does hell yeah
that'll help you know
we got a gang [__] yeah yeah you guys
gotta get a bunch on really [__] yeah we
got some [__] yeah yeah classic [__] too
I just keep those right you know yeah
probably just keep them I mean or just
work it out with his family because why
not bro help help him you know he's got
he's got a
he's got one kid I think right I think I
seen
yeah I think he's got a baby yeah I've
seen that I don't know I mean you know
[__] that [__] goes towards his family
you know what I'm saying like I'm sure
he would want his family to eat off that
oh hell yeah for sure
um
for you man like how do you feel about
uh
where
because the perception of
being a Mexican in hip-hop I think is
starting to become more like you're an
artist who I look I look at you like
you're an artist who just happens to be
Mexican you know what I'm saying yeah I
mean you're just making a lot of dope
[__] like yeah like
yeah you know what I'm saying but I'm
saying like for you do you feel that
that that like stigma going away where
it's like you know I feel like oh
Jeezy's help with that I feel like that
Mexican OT is helping with that you're
you're doing your thing with that but
like do you feel like you know now it's
like not as much a like
um an uphill battle to get people to
like respect you
hell no I feel like
look sometimes I feel like it's good but
then sometimes I feel like they do try
to boxes in but I mean I feel like we
just artists at the end of the day
that's it our skin color brown you know
like we're back an artist who just
happens to be like the music is dope
yeah hell yeah but I mean I feel like
we're doing our [__] I feel like they
gonna they gotta you know I mean we
going crazy like we're going down we're
doing some like bigger numbers than some
artists who it's just we just we rapping
it's hip-hop you know 100 it shouldn't
be uh we shouldn't be our own category I
agree I don't think we are either I
don't think we are either like I don't
think we are yeah no I think that I
don't think so but I think that like
there are still people who are like oh
yeah yeah like he's a dope Mexican
rapper and it's like well he's also just
a dope rapper
he's just a rapper who's dope and oh
he's Mexican yeah yeah yeah like Cypress
Hill back in the day were just hard like
you'd be like yo that's Cypress Hill dog
the [__] are hard like yeah
it's hard you know what I'm saying oh
yeah uh who give me um like you
obviously say you were inspired by nip a
lot but like when you were growing up
like what music were you listening to
what kind of helped form your uh your
style man
um uh nip for sure
like uh let me see who else I listening
to or that
um
man I can't even think off the top of my
[__] you feel me I listen to 50 too
you got the Melodies yeah 50 was hard
who else I'm trying to think
so yeah that's that's the best those
aren't bad yeah that's all I have to
think about type [__] I was it was more
but you know I just came off the top of
my head for sure I saw you uh you got
Greedo on the album shots of Greedo he
just came through a couple months ago uh
yeah man you're doing good he got that
[__] he got the [__]
rich guy teeth now you know what I'm
saying he got them pearly whites hell
yeah you know I had to get those too
where'd you go to get your teeth uh I
went to uh right here in Studio City oh
you did it out here yeah Dr uh Trevor
Trevor you know something everybody [__]
they hop on the plane and they'll go to
like uh Colombia Mexico pay two five
racks and they come back looking like
big ass fake ass you know white ass feet
I'm like oh like you don't even you
didn't even try to make them look real
yeah I'd be seeing that [__] too
[__] look like Jim Carrey The
Mask yeah yeah them teeth bro yeah uh
how how obviously the new Project's out
uh how much like music do you plan on
dropping throughout the rest of the year
are you keeping the pressure on them or
like what are you doing
yeah for sure I got I got hella [__] we
got projects lined up
videos are coming a whole lot of [__]
I'm just ready to you know go I'm ready
to go crazy yeah you know have you
tapped in with Bern it all who burner
burner I haven't I haven't I haven't had
family you gotta make that happen bro we
gotta make that [__] happen ASAP I [__]
with him too burner's a [__] real
life almost billionaire right now yeah
man he he a legend he's on the cover of
Forbes that's [__] like trying to get
on the cover before yo do you get like
like you were you were only locked up
for like what seven months yeah
what is like the craziest thing once you
get out that changes in a seven month
period because the world is kind of like
not the same every three months like
[__] happens there's drama there's like
inventions there's all kinds was there
anything that like was just like you got
out and you were like oh this [__] is
different now like
anything I mean yeah the suede [__] that
[__] [__] me up that [__] don't feel
real to me still
um let me see like
uh the music [__] too like I'm seeing D
baby go crazy that [__] is going crazy
yeah shout out D baby uh that [__] that
[__] I'm like damn you know that's
what's up I'm like what the [__] yeah
he's going on you know just seeing dope
[__] like that
um
that's about it other than that shit's
really the same yeah you know but just
seeing like certain people go up or like
some like you know some people are here
with us no more and uh [__] like that or
like the podcast too like seeing your
[__] I'm like damn you going crazy like
you know like you know
are you guys able to watch YouTuber [__]
in jail hell no hell no I always wonder
like not in the county not in the county
it's harder to get [__] in the county
yeah because it's actual like shares
right there like you know it's not CEOs
yeah it's like police officers yeah that
makes sense so like now you're you're a
cop like yeah you're a cop an actual cop
you're not gonna give us no phone action
yeah man I'd be like bro I'm like
everything I love I'd be like I send you
a thousand dollar cash app let me use
your phone for like 30 minutes
no what I swear thousand bucks I'm like
here you go cash out real quick bam damn
money
yeah yeah take it for the whole day do
you get do you get like uh like I'm
about to say how do you like do you guys
get [__] any sort of like tablet or
any porn
can't you get in trouble if you have
porn
sometimes you you know this
[__] coming back from upstate
and they got some [__] on them you feel
me and they'll sell it like yo give me
five soups for that wait they're selling
pornos not
um
give me five soups for that all right
give me 10 soups and [__] like putting
[__] on their bunks like I got all the
[__] right here you feel me I got it
all in here yes sir I got the spank bang
going sometimes that [__] ain't enough I
feel you that's real sometimes it ain't
enough it's hard you need to you need
that visual man everything oh I ain't
gonna lie though as soon as I got out
some [__] you were smacking I was right
I was hitting [__] in my paper suit I
still have my paper suit on anything I
love right as soon as you got out as
soon as I got out did you already have
it lined up like you knew who you were
like okay I know who I'm taking down
right away yeah it was my girl and [__]
so are you in a relationship yeah oh
well shots your girl yeah the way you
said it was like I was running it up
yeah